[موسيقى]
خصف الناس همهم فضول ايش حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل كل واحد
قادر يوقفهم ووقفها فزعو احنا قاعدين في
دورنا مش
طالعين لنف لنف لحد ما نرجع
لدورنا من نف لنف لحد ما نرجع لدورنا
طلعونا بنرجع وين اروح يعني عر دور مش
عارف وين
في اسكندر لا نصر
لافه لا سلامه لا الصبره ل
المعسكر مش عارفين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
و الجامع الغربي دار لستها هنا قيد
الانشاء دمروها شهدا الليله صار برضو قصف
بنايه على رؤوس
سكنيه لشهد الحال مش معروف ما حدش حاسس
فينا ما حدش
اي فيش حد قلبه رحيم والله العظيم ربنا هو
اللي ينقب فينا وبس حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
لجنا نوم الله يلتقم منهم والله الواحد
زهق زهق وهو يضل يشحط في اولاده من هان
لهان احنا رجعنا على دورنا دورنا مسحوقه
دورنا مبهدله مين السبب فيه هذا مين حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل على اللي هم السبب وعلى
كل الدول العربيه اللي ما هي راضيه تقف
معنا وبس
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل مالش غير ربنا يعني
ربنا سلمنا ب اربع مرات خمسه من القصر
الدور اللي جمنا يتقصف انت فهم
كيف شباب قدامنا تفتفت يعني تروح
شقف جبرنا
نطلع